à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes les
républicains ont souhaité être présents
la femme républicaine est une famille
libre en semi-mars mobilisons-nous pour
soutenir et défendre les droits des
femmes et faire en sorte que l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes soient
possibles alors que la gauche s'agite la
droite prône l'égalité non pas en
rivalité ni en matriarcat mais grâce à
de belles avancées comme le droit de
vote avec le général de Gaulle le doigt
l'IVG avec Simone Veil et alors que les
autres mouvements sont marqués par la
faiblesse de leurs actions la droite
républicaine demeure aujourd'hui depuis
plus de 70 ans le seul et unique
mouvement politique à avoir concrètement
œuvré pour le droit d'être car en effet
la droite républicaine s'est bien plus
qu'un parti de travail c'est bien plus
comme partie de méritocratie c'est avant
tout le parti du droit des femmes le
parti de la famille
Colas Sarkozy qui a su accorder sa
confiance à des femmes pour occuper des
ministères régaliens je pense à Rachida
Dati qui a été nommé garde des sceaux et
qui dans le cadre de son portefeuille il
y a beaucoup oeuvré dans le cadre de la
violence faite contre les femmes et puis
aussi sur les sujets d'égalité salariés
alors qu'en France en 2022 60000 femmes
sont encore excisées alors qu'on trouve
encore des écarts salariaux de
15,8%. alors que de nombreux féminicides
sont encore recensés c'est d'autres
devoir c'est celui de la droite
française de se saisir de ces questions
à la fois de sécurité mais aussi de
santé publique la misogynie l'inégalité
salariale les violences conjugales le
voile comme instrument de soumission
pour nous citer que ces exemples sont
autant de combat que nous devons mener
chaque jour alors à la question peut-on
être féministe et de droite la réponse
est oui être féministe et de c'est
d'assumer les différences comme une
complémentarité et non comme une
discrimination structurelle chez les
républicains on s'est donné à sa chance
aux femmes Éric Ciotti notre président
m'a confié une responsabilité importante
puisque je préside aujourd'hui le comité
des maires et des élus locaux un comité
qui est parfaitement paritaire j'invite
à celles qui sont aujourd'hui élus ou
qui aspirent l'être à nous rejoindre
donc nous femmes républicaine nous
continuerons de soutenir les femmes à
chaque étape de leur vie en leur donnant
elle est moyen de réussir parce qu'elles
sont à des femmes libres ce mercredi
nous célébrons les femmes du monde
entier et je pense particulièrement à la
situation des femmes afghane et
iraniennes l'égalité homme-femme fait
encore partie des domaines dans lesquels
nous ne pouvons plus attendre que les
choses changent d'elles-mêmes alors
mobilisons-nous ensemble pour faire
avancer notre société vers plus
d'égalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]